hi everyone it's Jerry I am going to
play a 1510 game
let's start out with D4
opponents rating for this game is 1054.
finest piece ever
okay
D4 D5 game
let's put some pressure on the center
the flank Pawn
Okay so
Queen's Gambit accepted
I'm going to start with Knight F3
this is a move I want to prevent my
opponent was just in pre-move mode
which is kind of surprising considering
it's an increment game
I just moved E3
or maybe even E4
um
actually I think after
E4
this may be a move
so I just want to Simply develop my
knight to F3 and stop any E4 advance I
can't play E4 now
and I do want to make sure I get this
Pawn back
as soon as possible so
E3 is almost certainly
gonna be played any other move
not really I don't want to try and track
down the pawn with the queen
E3 is
a good follow-up just looking to regain
the pawn
and develop
can't ask for too much more
all right
this Pawn is unprotected
I could simply regain the pawn now
I am in a pin
not too concerned about questioning the
bishop just yet let's just make sure
I capture this pawn and in fact I'm
threatening some tricks now
with 94. Bishop takes Queen
could be met with Bishop takes F7
checkmate
and we may see that right now
so I actually have two Pleasant choices
to either take on F7 with Chuck
and after King takes to then play Knight
to E5 winning the bishop
because it would be hit twice
or to first play night
E5
and which one is objectively best
I'm thinking it's the forceful approach
because if I play this one first
black it does have the option
to not take my queen
and instead bring the bishop back to E6
which is very ugly because after takes
there's going to be double isolated
pawns but
I haven't won a pawn
okay
I may want to also consider let's see if
I play this and Bishop to E6 Bishop
takes Pawn takes maybe then Queen B3
as mentioned earlier B7 is unprotected
my queen would be hitting both of these
points
however
there is a convenient reply in Queen D5
offering a queen exchange and defending
both B7 and D6
so what does this mean
I think it means best is to First Take
on F7
takes 95 check
and then simply win the bishop
so as soon as this move was played
something the black could have already
been saying to themselves was
that F7 is unprotected one attacker one
Defender
okay
I think would have what would have been
better than G6 is E6
yeah I'm gonna go with what I I feel is
objectively best
that is to take on F7
even though this may tempt a lot of
players
to go ahead and take that Queen
I think this is the correct way to
approach it
not looking to play uh hope chess
all right so we have the follow-up just
finishing this tactical sequence
my knight could end up a little bit
clumsy in a way on G4 if the Knight
exchange is ducked
um
may run the risk of
you know some H5 idea but
is there something better here actually
this this move is kind of crossing my
mind but no still this idea to play
Queen D5 and stop any
Queen F7 move is there so I guess we
simply
get the piece back and okay so they are
taking I think
you know to try and put up more
resistance there is black probably best
to keep the tension and maybe carry on
with development
is however slight this is I'm now able
to recapture and improve a piece
so it's it's moves like this you know if
I'm playing as black that move
I would think twice about doing that
because
if my opponent's able to recapture and
move forward
it's usually an improvement
Okay so
I am currently up a pawn
my opponent is on castled this Bishop's
going to have a tough time
coming out
what might this night be looking to do
next possibly this move
but I'm not I'm not too concerned about
that
I really don't think there's a better
Square than C3 for the night
I don't think it's worthwhile to invest
too tempy to get to F3
this is an excellent Square for a night
but
you factor in the time
I don't know that it's really worthwhile
um
I wonder
this move is crossing my mind to stop
the pawn from advancing but I would
expect
the queen to be challenged if I play
Knight C3 and then E5 is in
I guess I could follow up with the D5
and there is a way I could go wrong with
Knight C3 E5 takes Knight takes hitting
my queen and then there's going to be
this check and my king is going to be
uncastled I don't want that I want to
just Castle
but I think
first just this one and on this I could
play here in on that move then I could
Castle I'm not too concerned about this
hitting
it's just one piece attacked once I'm
castled so
I'm gonna go with Knight C3 Queen Knight
on C3 King Knight on F3
ideal squares
however with the queen Knight
in many cases you'll want to make sure
you're not really obstructing a c Pawn
in in d-pawn based openings
C Pawn likes to be on C4
before Knight C3
all right so here we are I think this is
a a good try and I think I do well to
not take on E5 and
carry on with D5 also worth noting
the bishop is defending
a knight jump into B5 okay
so retreat
some pressure on this Pawn
this is the first move that crosses my
mind
I guess this is another
mixing defense with attack
um
if this
I open up my Bishop size
I do a good job controlling the Knight
and if I control the Knight I control
the bishop
can't get out
however after E4 I'm wondering
about this E6 move maybe
in reply to E6 there then I could play
Queen here
yeah that's looking like the correct way
um
yeah I think I like this idea
it's a very healthy
like
having a pawn control an enemy night
so I'm still up the pond now with this
last move I could even start to
view the position as you know I have the
I have a better Bishop
these pawns are now fixed we have some
definition in the position
[Music]
um
oh good Bishop
ties in well with my fixed Center Pawn
on a light
okay so the Knight is looking to reroute
to better Square
I am on move
Bishop G5 it's tempting
but as mentioned I do have
the better bishop and if this move is
played I think that is a convenient
reply and I don't know that I really
want to
and go for a dark Square Bishop exchange
so
I think I just want a castle
this Castle
a knight to F6 I could fall back
this is a cozy Square
and what's running through my mind now
is
how to activate my Rooks
I'm also looking for a stable Square for
my queen
so E6 could be challenged with a queen
I mean I wouldn't mind a queen Exchange
but in having the safer King
I think I wanna
maybe try and get at this guy
uh let's see
we need two Queenie six
yeah if this there's probably that
Queen takes Bishop takes
it could go into an ending
but
me
no I actually come to think of it after
Queen to E6 there's Bishop D6 and then
my queen is going to be kicked away
she's
it's a very active square but I'm not
really tied in with any other white
piece so
I think I'm just gonna fall back to a
comfortable square and stay out of my f
ponds way I have this on my mind
and I think I want to play it right now
the same time some check to make
I am vulnerable on this diagonal but
this isn't
really going anywhere after King H1
no other black piece is able to quickly
tie in with it
like there's no follow-up Knight G4 so
I think this is healthy
opens up a file for my Rook maybe even
looks forward to playing F5
something's going to open
okay how to recapture
with the piece
the bishop
you know what piece the bishop okay
that's sensible
I do have now an unopposed Center
two to zero
I'd like to give this Knight a push
but I'd be dropping this
I could set that up activate my queen
Rook
this is the only piece that's currently
not playing
I didn't have to make any moves with my
Rook for it to contribute just
Pawn play with F4
so
I could consider a battery looking for
some material now let's not forget about
this too
maybe even consider Bishop to E5
trying to do something on the pin
although after that move I don't know
where I'm going
okay this Rook isn't doing anything
uh let's get it doing something
let me let me check this this and then
right here is not really working because
there's Knight takes Bishop
to get out of the pin Rook takes Queen
Knight takes Queen check
so let's just defend D5 directly
and this now sets up E5 this is a past
Pawn after all
my E Pawn
and now they are walking right into E5 I
I could play this and there isn't any
fear of a pin
because I could take the night with
Chuck so
yeah that one's coming
so oh you know what I'm not winning
material because the bishop gets out
with check my mistake
yeah but this is still good
but uh I was mistaken to think
I'm winning material okay I am winning
material the bishop check was not
spotted so
probably going to win even more material
I don't think there's anything better
than taking the night with Chuck
this could hit
yeah
so Bishop to E5 piece is on the same
diagonal this guy's eyes light right up
the check isn't anything
and this one's officially collapsing
material plus really no concern about
counter play in a position like this
the conversion shouldn't be
too difficult
of the material
okay
and
I don't think it really matters I guess
I guess I'll take with the pawn
this isn't going anywhere
I like to keep those pins for as long as
possible
until my opponent has to expend a move
to get out of it
it's only then I'll consider more
closely the capture
Okay so
I'm gonna take with the Rook
and this sets up a discovery
okay so I feel like it should be
Checkmate in just a handful of moves
this stroke is no longer needed on D1
this is the better
file let's get there
I can't move my Bishop
um
I could play here
there's a queen check but I have Bishop
lock I'm gonna go in for this one
I don't mind giving up both Rooks for
the queen at this point
okay and earlier I was pointing out king
H1 but I do have
a counter-attacking move and I should be
going with that
sort of get the move back
and now this is nearby
and it should be made in just a few
where's the mate
I think you start with that one
this queen takes Bishop
not seen the not seen the mate
like a for a forceful mate
check here check
and it's unnecessary to really calculate
any of that I think just one
simple move of getting the a second
major piece
to the seventh Rank and
there's now
multiple mate threats
check checkmate
yeah we'll go with that one
it is double check
I know that's unnecessary a single check
is fine
got mate there mate there
okay however you slice it
okay
a good game I'm typing my way
or typing my opponent's way let's have a
look at this one
analysis board
and let me do a computer
analysis real quick we'll get to see the
the accuracy for both sides and
I think mostly I was able to share
everything I wanted to throughout this
game Queen's Gambit
accepted
and it was just an opening error right
here I mean this is this is a fine move
it's not considered best
is normally this idea to play E6
and Asics with the idea of playing next
on the queen side with the
B4 C5 ideas
so as an example E6 I regained the pawn
and then A5 or excuse me A6
let's say a castle
then there's B5 or C5 suggesting C5
first
but I don't think there's anything super
wrong with that one it prefers I guess
maybe if you're doing this a little too
soon you may be subjected to in a quick
A4
so this idea to challenge the center
with the flank Pawn is there
and this is still
a possibility but this is this is the
more
accurate more
Yeah the more accurate approach
but as played right here as soon as this
guy's here to view that as unprotected
should it should definitely grab Black's
attention e6s
the move to play after that one it
should just be over from that point on
um
again as mentioned Knight here is
tempting
the bishop to E6
you know if that then we'd have a quick
mate
but
yeah it is
considered Queen B3 even Queen B3
I could have considered that wasn't on
my mind
it's just torn between these two
and it should just be downhill from
there really isn't
it's just an opening error
in the end
95 accuracy 84 accuracy
okay just uh
a 15-10 game
against finest piece ever
uh that's about it for this one Feel
Free as usual to leave any feedback to
this video in the comments section below
hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye